foreign
High Penelope welcome to the Ramsey Show
um I am on the stepson I paid off my
house sort of mid-september of last year
but my credit score has not gone to zero
it's hovering in sort of the 647 area
and I'm obviously excited for it to go
to zero I was wondering you should it be
there by now or is there something else
I could do to make it go to zero
foreign
well it doesn't matter because you're
not going to be borrowing money but it
is a it's just something we want to see
happen here I don't disagree with you so
the deal that we what we understand now
listen FICO they run their deal and they
keep their algorithm they keep their
formula under lock and key so no one
knows for sure but all we've been able
to do is observe Ramsay followers that
when they have 100 of their accounts
closed down zero balance no activity no
outstanding bad credit nothing on the
bureau it's squeaky clean when you pull
up all three of your Credit Bureau
reports you go to Experian you go to
everybody you look at every one of them
and you make sure there's not a single
thing showing up not any uh Eight dollar
water bill from eight years ago that you
forgot was on there that'll keep it down
there at 600. you know it's got you
gotta have
100 clean usually in six six months to
nine months it's gone if you're 100 zero
balances no activity on the account
yeah that's what I thought too I've had
seen soft inquiries from you know like
insurance companies and you know just
stuff like that but other than that yeah
and all closed accounts and yeah no
activity you can put marketing blocks on
and keep the soft inquiries down uh but
you haven't you haven't had any hard
inquiries where you applied for
something even a cell phone or anything
like that nope nope nothing like that
hmm yeah well the okay what we usually
find when it's taking much longer than
six months is somebody's got something
open on there of some kind that's what
you want to go back and triple check
that and check it with all three of them
all three of the credit bureaus uh and
not just one and not just Credit Karma
okay so get in there and if you're
really concerned about this and you are
enough to call here so you got to do
that but zero activity uh should for six
months and no accounts open there's no
credit history there to score should get
you to an indeterminable or a zero
credit score which I've had for well
over 30 years that's kind of fun